[Music]
hello
and welcome to diversity and leadership
connect with community
um i've been looking forward to this
session all week long with our black
business student association
partially because they're just awesome
humans and partially because i just
really enjoy sharing
space with them so as folks continue to
join
um we're gonna go ahead and start
introducing some of our students here
um so what we're going to do is if you
can please introduce
your name what you were doing pre gsb
and what you hope to do next so
if we can kick off with ori
hi everybody um my name is ori pre
gsb uh right before the gsb i was
actually working at
eli lilly and company in pharma and
started strategy um
and post gsb i hope to get back to my
roots in media and television um so
we'll see how that goes
nice is there a particular part uh area
of television that you're interested in
or media
yes uh streaming services so i worked at
amazon studios this summer in production
and hope to return there or go somewhere
like netflix or hulu
coming out of the gsp nice
and then uh micah
yup my name is micah greenberg before
coming to the gsb
i was in dc working in international
development mostly focused on
public service delivery in
non-regime-held areas of syria
and post-gsb i'm transitioning into real
estate and local economic development
oh interesting can you sorry to cold
call you already but like
what inspired you for the pivot
um in terms of real estate
yeah i think have just kind of done a
lot of
um soul-searching and what i want to be
doing and where i want to be
and what i want the content of my work
to look like and it feels like real
estate
is the building block of what makes a
city work or not work for its residents
so starting at the foundation there
nice all right so and then
asha yeah hi everyone
um i worked in commercial real estate
finance actually so the field mike is
going into i actually worked in that
field
before i came to the gsb uh spent five
years doing that
and i came here to pivot out of finance
and actually go into entrepreneurship i
just launched my startup
back in july it's called mediocracy it's
a beauty retail startup
um so really excited to be diving
headfirst into
entrepreneurship fundraising vcs etc and
my goal is to work on this startup full
time after graduation
hi i'm wes um prior to the gsb
i worked in the investment management
space and will be
pivoting to consulting after graduation
um in the long term really interested in
promoting greater financial inclusion
primarily for
underrepresented communities here in the
us and have been pursuing
fintech in parallel with consulting
nice cool so could um warrior west can
you please talk tell us a little bit
uh more about vvsa
yeah um i'm happy since uh since the
mike's on me i'm happy to kick off and
uh worry eyes and michael feel free to
to add on um i think first and foremost
uh bbsa is is a family and
um i think that's that family has been
more important this year um than really
ever
before um and
and really it's it aligns with our
mission like we the
our primary aim is to be a support
system for the black gsb community and
and um but but you know we we like to
to do a little bit more than that and i
think we've expanded
kind of our mandate as an organization
uh quite a bit over the past year
um so we in addition to holding
uh hosting social events and community
building events within
our membership group we also host a
number of events that
kind of open up our community to the
broader gsb community and broader
business community
so kind of the two key
events that we hold um are one
we host a series of series of events um
during black history month that really
um showcase um black excellence in the
business community to
to the broader gsb and then um i won't
steal her thunder but
kind of our marquee annual event is our
bbsa
conference in gala which which aja is is
leading the effort for
this this next year where we really
bring in a number of alums number of
senior leaders across
all facets of business to
um to share their experience with folks
here at the gsb but also the surrounding
barrier community which is
and that's been really a highlight um
and the last thing is we we
try to build connections with
um the broader black community at
stanford so
we engage with faculty with the
administration
with our comparable groups and other
graduate programs
and a lot of us mentor um some of the
black undergrads as well
um so uh it's it's fairly open-ended and
um you know it's just a great
opportunity for us to support each other
and
and share our experience with the
broader uh
broader community nice so actually
since we just mentioned it asha could
you tell us a little bit more about
um the conference in gala yeah of course
so the conference in gala is an annual
event that the bbsa holds
it's a typically a two-day event
although this year with covet it's posed
some unique opportunities for us to sort
of change the way we host the event this
year but
typically it's over two days friday and
saturday and it's really an
amazing opportunity for us to tap on uh
to the resources here at stanford and
bring people together amongst
not just our community but other
stanford communities the law school it's
the
the uh um
across the board but then also to be
able to connect with alumni it's one of
the best opportunities for us to connect
with the black alumni at the school
and the black professionals in the bay
area so it's this really cool uniting
event
that allows us to bring some of these
top uh individuals
onto our campus and have panels
discussions
um keynote speakers we've had some
pretty impressive people in the past and
it's been a really great opportunity to
network and the gal has always been fun
it's probably our
our favorite event of the year and it's
really a way for us to connect with
alumni
uh in a more intimate setting it's
limited to a couple of hundred people
we actually acknowledge and present an
award to
a distinguished alumni every year and
it's just a really fantastic
time to celebrate i think past gsberries
and alumni and current students
and the work that we've done and the
work that we intend to do in the future
nice so that's one of the large events i
know wes you alluded to some uh
like other events throughout the year so
maybe if anybody on this group could
talk a little bit about maybe an event
that was really meaningful for you
um over the past you know year or so
i can kick off um we we just came off of
our
fall retreat for bbsa which was
meaningful for me this year and last
year
it's um our first opportunity to welcome
the black students from phds mba ones
mba twos all together
um and getting to just meet each other
and
uh learn about how we want to what we
want the bbsa community to
be for us think that's a really great
way to kick off the year so that we all
come in with that intention of we wanted
to be a family we wanted to be
supportive
this year he said we want us all to win
like professionally
relationship wise like all of these
things and how we can support each other
to get us to that end goal
so that was really good and asha helped
plan like
an a wellness session that like micah
and aj are like big wellness people and
that was really important um this year
and was just a wonderful way to kick off
this community for for this school year
i would also say this is something that
we haven't mentioned yet but
the other thing that ori west and asha's
bbsa leadership have done this year
is really take up a mantle and a role to
be advocates for the black community and
black students at stanford
at large and within the business school
and there was an event where
kind of the three of them put together a
really amazing
presentation based on feedback from
students alumni
and the like to give to the
administration of like these are the
needs
of black students at stanford that
aren't being met currently and here's
literally a like bcg level plan
could have been twenty thousand dollars
it was free because of these guys
analysis of how you achieve these like
your recommendations
and i think that was probably one of my
most impactful experiences with this
group outside of just the
relation like really great relationships
that i've gotten from it
yeah i have to give all of you so much
credit and gratitude and thanks for the
work you've done
kind of for the institution as a whole
as well as
in partnership with the mba admissions
office thank you for
always being there to help us continue
to improve what we do and how we do it
and so i don't want to that to be kind
of
a missed subtext at all thank you so
much and i just want to make sure that
everybody on this call knows how much
i appreciate each and every one of you
and so there actually is a question in
the q a box i'm going to
have this be an organic
if at all possible and i think with the
topic you started micah
i think we can go ahead and jump into
this question a little bit this is from
robert
who would love to hear about how gsb has
been leveraging the group
and the organization about ongoing
dialogue
and how that's evolved over time
especially given
kind of the situation from this year so
any insights
or maybe either um things of from the
list of recommendations you found
especially profound or meaningful
yeah i can i can kick off there and um
others feel free to
time in i think um you know micah
alluded to this
we've been spending a lot of time um
thinking through ways we can
make the gsb um you know
and and an even better environment for
for members of our black community and
and um really for everyone um to feel
included and supported and
um as you can imagine earlier this year
um
you know there was an increased appetite
for
resources for understanding around um
dei topics and that was a big component
of what we were advocating for
the institution to kind of put its put
its weight behind
one thing that we've we've been you know
in addition to us just
having some of these conversations and
supporting each other within the
community
um one thing that's been really
inspiring has been
the level of engagement with with allies
within the broader community so um
uh some of our classmates um you know
created a um a group called allies for
black lives within the gsb that's
um kind of taken much of the burden off
of our community in terms of sharing
information
around educating on these topics and and
has
rallied um you know many many groups
outside of even the identity groups at
stanford to support what we're
advocating for within the gsb and
i think that um that
in addition to much of the work that um
the student association
in particular the the diversity
committee has been doing to
um create um foundational
um programming early in the nba
experience to
inform and create space for people to
have these discussions
um all that's come together and uh you
know there's certainly room for
tremendous room for improvement but it's
been inspiring to see
um our student community really activate
and
um you know really fill in some of the
gaps that you know we're working to
to close
yeah i think west said it very well um i
would add on to that
that we've equally been able to connect
with the
alumni and do some i think some
impressive work with our alumni in
conjunction with the administration
this year and has really opened up an
opportunity for us to
um have the administration's
ear in a way that i don't think we
necessarily had before and so we've
really
taken that opportunity to have some
really important conversations around
what we want to see at the gsv
and what we want to see the gsb do
broadly and i think equally so we've
been able to work
more closely than in previous years with
our black alumni
and what the work that they have been
doing um
that's sort of been out of our peer view
in the past but really we've been able
to like really bring these two things
together i actually lead the initiative
with the alumni and we're working on
programming
within the school and they're equally um
and talks
with the administration so there's
there's a lot that's happening
this year that the bbsa is a part of and
i think that
um you know we really i think and i
admire wesson uh
ori's leadership as bbsa presidents to
take
this opportunity to actually um lead
these conversations forward and see that
we see progress out of
uh out of this year in particular
there is some interest there's actually
a lot of interest in
what are like some general categories or
realms
um that were presented in the
the report to administration where areas
that the gsb could improve
yeah i can i can start and anyone jump
in to fill in
the gaps but i think when we were
putting together
the presentation we we thought about the
different
populations at the gsb and how we could
improve representation and then sense of
belonging across
all those um populations so
faculty staff students um
and then the gsb's impact beyond just
the campus
um and so of course that looks like
increasing numbers
more black faculty more black students
more black staff but once they get there
and get here how do they
feel part of this community and
supported by this community
and that includes training for people
that are not you know used to dei
conversations
um that means supporting students via
financial aid
um more so that because we know that
this is a big gap for why black students
don't end up attending um business
school because of that massive financial
lift
um and that means that when they're in
the classroom when we're in the
classroom who are we learning from
what kind of cases are we learning about
do they feature
protagonists from different backgrounds
so i think
those are like broad strokes but um a
lot of what we discussed and wanting
students alumni faculty staff
administration to all have
a hand in shaping what that will look
like and
we know that this work is not just one
and done that it's ongoing
and so a critical piece of our
recommendation was that there needs to
be some accountability piece that lives
on beyond
our graduation and so um the
administration has created
a dei council that has
faculty staff alumni students that will
live on to hold
the administration accountable for years
to come so really excited about that as
well
and another thing that came directly out
of these efforts
was that um financial aid is now going
to be having
is piloting this year a supplemental
program
where our need we have need-based
financial aid
um however that doesn't always examine
some of the structural
wealth gaps or resource gaps that might
happen because of
systemic and structural racism and that
inheritance
and so this kind of supplemental funding
is going to go to students generally who
might
because of like circumstances or other
factors
um need additional supplemental support
it's not specifically racially based
um but i think it is something that's so
needed for the gsb and i think is
representative of the ways that kind of
like
advocacy for black and brown people and
from black and brown communities really
moves
the whole school and the whole community
forward
yeah and um that fund is the bold
fellows fund and
i actually do want to credit essentially
ori and aja for helping advise
and contribute to the development of it
and as we launch it
we're so thankful and grateful and know
that it's going to keep growing
um thanks to your help so just want to
make sure
all the folks out there know again how
much i appreciate you
so as you're thinking about like
your time at the gsb beyond advocacy as
we're thinking about our own
kind of personal growth and development
um what were some of the things that
drew you to the gsb
i uh so i was um in a peculiar
precarious place when i was trying to
figure out where i wanted to go at
three schools that i was thinking
through um and it was
very it was very close for me what
really drew me to the gsb
uh was in particular first and foremost
the community
it was about connecting with the class
size that i felt like i could actually
manage
and actually be able to connect with the
majority of my classmates i was really
focused on
quality over quantity so quantity so i
really wanted to develop these deeper
relationships
um and there was this focus of the gsb
about collaboration
both in the classroom and outside of the
classroom that was really important to
me
um having as an entrepreneur
being at stanford uh for me was a
a major plus it was about tapping into
an existing network of
entrepreneurs and entrepreneurship not
just within the gsb but within the area
the bay area
palo alto sand hills so it was really
about being in
uh the center of an ecosystem for
entrepreneurship and fundraising that
was really
valuable for me can you talk a little
bit more about that are there specific
moments or like aha situations that have
helped you along
your entrepreneurial journey yeah i
would say
the first year uh you know that i
joined the venture studio which is um
a i guess a community space that's on
the gsp's campus but it's really
um open up i think to the entire
university but it's it was a really
wonderful community that i could sort of
bounce ideas off with off of
and sort of get some advice um i found
the center for entrepreneurial studies
to be kind of helpful in figuring out
what
what kind of experimental and
experiential classes i wanted to take
during my time at the gsb i actually
landed in startup garage this year
and that's been incredibly helpful for
me startup garage has been a really
amazing opportunity for me to connect
with two classmates who i hadn't worked
with in a
sort of official capacity before but
really got closer with and we did some
really amazing work
in startup garage over the last quarter
and then i would say
uh what i found to be most valuable was
the faculty and the lecturers like
some of these classes um are really
tactical and they're very practical and
we were
we had vcs as lecturers we had people
who were actually actively investing and
actively
um talking to entrepreneurs um in their
day-to-day
who were lecturing in the classroom and
um being able to talk to these
individuals about
and actually ask them about things that
they were solving real time or
real circumstances or entrepreneurs they
could connect me with was really big
so it was about getting access to that
network and like connecting with those
individuals and that for me was really
impactful
particularly this year yeah nice
um before we go to what drew other folks
you tapped into a question that has been
a recurring theme over the course of the
week
so that accessibility piece so um just
for the group
continuing along that thread of like
faculty or experts like
how would you describe like your
experience um with like the educational
ecosystem here
[Music]
yeah i would say um
i came in without a lot of background in
kind of traditional
business i'm a non-traditional mba
student
um so just about everything was new
and i can't say that i'm a connoisseur
of like the names in the business world
but we have the names of the business
world even if i haven't heard of them
before
so it has been really a crash course in
having
really um smart and really renowned and
experienced
people at your fingertips and available
if you so know about them and choose to
engage
um and i think i've also
in terms of just like the faculty
accessibility of experience has been
pretty wonderful
um especially as a student without the
background have met with several
professors who are like brilliant and
lauded in their field and have them
explain a balance sheet you know and
walk through how to do basic accounting
calculations
and get a lot of empathy and excitement
there as well as the ability to talk
about
more interesting and sophisticated
topics
so i've definitely found just faculty
who want to engage
and want to know students by and large
which has been really wonderful
just to build on that i feel like
stanford is like opportunity overload
and i i went here undergrad
and um so i've taken a lot of classes
across the street as well
and it's like all of stanford is kind of
at your disposal
um the faculty across the street are
really excited to talk to you
at the d school or other other programs
are open to having
business school students from law school
with med school so
it feels like there's a lot of
opportunity to take advantage of
while i've been here
have folks taking classes outside of the
gstb
yeah can you give a couple of examples
maybe
i took a really amazing um class
called need finding in a while and then
an intensive interviewing course
and essentially it's by these two
practitioners
who are incredibly skilled and smart who
essentially
four companies do um kind of exercises
to elevate products and so
like the person who had done all of the
research to get like
pampers or huggies to have pull-ups like
they had noticed that like
you know you have a child in diapers but
it doesn't really fit their
developmental stage so there needs to be
a step between diapers and like
underwear and it's pull-ups but like who
knew you know
so that was a really wonderful course
that i took in the design school
i took chinese all last year an advanced
conversational chinese class and that
was
the highlight of my week and next
quarter i'm so excited to take
a tv scriptwriting class and python
because you know stanford like invented
computers or whatever so
good to know how to use them and code
and do fun stuff like that
sorry i kind of got off track just
because everybody was
giving such a great like areas and on
ramps but
for um so audra mentioned some of what
drew her to campus
so coming back to that idea like for or
us micah what are some of the things
that drew you to campus
um i think my answer is has a lot of
overlap with with what i just shared i
think i'd come from
a pretty traditional finance background
and
um with entrepreneur
entrepreneurship as a long-term vision
for me knew that it was important for me
to
place myself in an environment that was
going to
um really push me to take risk um but
risks and thoughtful ways um around
entrepreneurship and innovation and um i
think i'm still on that journey and
that's that's really a focus
for this year in terms of some of that
exploration but i think just being in
this ecosystem like there's so much
um so much that you gain almost through
osmosis
just being around the conversations that
are taking place
here and in the surrounding community um
i think
you know having a chance to even to hear
about the great work that is doing
hear about hear hear from others in our
class it
it keeps the itch there um to
to continue to push towards creating uh
versus versus just following and
um i think i appreciate constantly being
challenged in that front and
um and and yeah i think
it's really just the the community that
we have around
around innovation and entrepreneurship
that inspires me
cool so anything anything to add ori or
mica
kind of things about the gsb that spoke
to you
i think i just got really good um
like had really good interactions in
revisiting the school after being
admitted and especially
from kind of the bbsa and just other
students like
i remember eating meeting ori on revisit
day and was just like i'm gonna be
friends with this girl she is awesome
so smart like so kind so welcoming um
and that was the general felt like the
general atmosphere of the school which
definitely kind of played in
i don't know if you can really
differentiate like a lot of these
schools offer great opportunities and so
kind of from that point it's like maybe
where you feel most comfortable
so true um there's a really interesting
kind of
trajectory of three questions here so
um a triumvirate of follow shelby
and sophia i mean let's see sophia's
question will be next so dakota
follow and shelby about um
how have your career aspirations kind of
evolved over time have they
and then what have been some of the
resources that helped you
explore that and or launched them
so interest and then how did you kind of
tap into that at the gsb was the career
management center part of it
was its alumni how did you experience
things
so give you a moment to
process that meaty question
um i'll i'll jump in i'm very much i'm
still very much on that journey
of of kind of piecing it together but
one experience that i had left
last year that that helped me narrow my
focus a bit was um
participating in the gsb impact fund so
i knew that
um you know fintech financial inclusion
it was a space i wanted to explore but i
wasn't sure which which vehicle
um i wanted to leverage to to drive the
impact that i was passionate about
whether that would be
you know advising um investing
or or being an operator and i think
impactfun and just this background and
the the impact fund is is
an early stage impact focused
vc um that's entirely student-run here
at the gsb
um and as part of that the teams
organized into
various industry verticals and i had a
chance to be on the
fintech investment team and um you're
giving
you're given a ton of autonomy in terms
of sourcing deals
learning about the space and really is a
chance to test all three
where you're you have to go through the
entire
investment due diligence process put
together an investment memo do the
financial modeling but at the same time
you're you're building relationships
with
with really um awesome founders
um in a field in which that for me it
was it was a great
way to get to know the the industry much
better and i think my
my takeaway from that was okay like
really
it's really fascinating the investment
side but for me i think the passion
would be
like i'm more excited about being on the
other side of that conversation than
being an operator
and i think that's guided um some of the
steps i've taken
on the back end of that but um so that's
just one plug for
kind of an opportunity to drive some
real-time impact um
while you're here but also um do add
some structure to that that exploration
that i know a lot of us
are looking to do that first year
um i i echo west that i'm still on the
journey as well
just because i came to the gsb with so
many interests and i felt like
i only had one summer so what can i do
um
and how can i figure out what i want to
do for my life and
a couple things helped me sort that out
one was actually a conversation i had
with dean moss early in the year where
she was like you don't have to
um choose really you can just explore
the things you want to explore um and
that really helped me
lay out that some of my interests like
in media i would explore
be an internship but some of my
interests in
helping my family's business i can
explore a lot through classes and with
my professors and so
i took the family business class i
worked on the family business projects
and taking like the
the classes with um professors that
started and launched their family
businesses too
so um just knowing that there is more
than just
one way to explore my career has been
really helpful for me
and i leveraged the cmc a lot i felt
like there
a lot of those folks are my mini
therapists a little bit and doing like
life mapping to figure out what i want
to do so
um it's okay if you don't know exactly
what's next um
and there's a lot there are a lot of
resources to figure out what could that
that could be
yeah see the cmc the career management
center it's pretty awesome
um just some some great people there so
um i'd like to shift focus um back to
bvsa if that's okay
um which is really the focus of today's
session and so
um question here from sophia
was um how
how do you balance um being part of a
growing black community at the gsb
um with involvement in other communities
without feeling like siloed or
pigeonholed and how do
the communities interact with bsa so
that interaction
among groups as well
i can speak to that um i would say
like one thing that you'll find about
all stanford students and maybe this is
mba students in general
is that we're over involved and over
indexed
um and so for better and or worse i
can't really think of anyone
in our community who's specifically
siloed or pigeonholed
in that like people have to and do play
a lot of different roles and hats are
involved kind of across the
across the gsb social universe
um i would say personally bbsa has
functioned as kind of like a home based
landing page
and has like has been kind of just a
really amazing support network
and a place that i found some really
deep relationship and just general
community
um but in no means is it my only kind of
social community and like
have roommates who i've met through
other kind of interest areas and have
kind of groups of friends that i went on
like international trips with and like
you know made friends that way so i
think i have been in other environments
where
kind of a school community feels more
segregated
or siloed or pigeonholed in that way um
and it doesn't feel like that here and
and like i even like i'd like to hang
out more with like
all of the black community but they're
very busy so it's sometimes hard
there as well um
yeah i think micah you touched on a
number of the points that i had i think
um i would add on that to say
the interaction between groups which i
think is like the second part of that
question
i think for for one every group is a
little bit different because every group
has different members so every group
sort of interacts with each other and
they have their own sort of system of
what events they have etc
um but we all work nicely with each
other um there is a lot of overlap and
interaction because
uh the gsb is an intersectional place so
a lot of people
within the gsb fall into multiple
categories you might be jewish you might
be
mixed you might be uh you know you might
speak a language whatever be from a
different place so like there's a lot of
intersectionality amongst
us and because of that there's a lot of
overlap with what we do with other
groups and so we spend a lot of time
talking to other groups connecting with
other groups
um you know ensuring that we don't like
playing over each other's events etc
because we all want to be a part of
what's happening and so i think there's
that's the beauty of that
is that ability sort of to connect and
to
feel like you know you're you're a part
of the bbsa but in a lot of ways you're
part of the school and the bbsa is like
a subsection of that
ex greater experience that you're having
all right and here's here's a question
from from anna
um what were some of the most
challenging hurdles you had to overcome
um as you joined the gsb whether as
individually
or as kind of a minority student and how
has bbsa
um like how have you leaned on being psa
and
um through that process
yeah i would i could i can start off i
think for me
um i was coming from the east coast i
was in washington dc
before i came to stanford i had never
lived in california
has lived maybe four days in the bay
area before i
moved to stanford so moving to the bay
area in general i think was difficult
for me
uh because the there was a complete
change in the demographics of the area
um and the school so it it definitely
um was an adjustment for me in the first
couple of months um being in an area
where the
black population was so small um and
uh honestly it operated differently than
it does on the east coast because of the
size of the population so
i think for me because of that i leaned
heavily on the bvsa and they were
and i found a lot of community on campus
within the gsb
um within the bbsa and then within my
classmates who
you know were very focused on building
relationships and creating community
in the school i think it's sort of like
the blessing and the curse of being at
stanford on the farm right you're like
you're in this bubble
and there's not a lot going on not a lot
going on around you but because of that
you spend a lot of time with your
classmates so you actually i think get
closer
than you might if you have say a city to
sort of expand out into so
um i would say that was probably the
hardest adjustment and then just getting
back into
the mode of school on top of that so
trying to figure out the social scene
um figuring out where i fit in um
you know on top of like trying to get
back into academics it was a little
overwhelming so i i found that being
able to
rely on you know the bbsa and the people
around me
in that adjustment period was really
helpful
same for me um i
i rely on the bbs my bbsa community for
everything it feels like um uh
helping me with career helping me with
um like relationship
issues all the things and um i remember
uh we have sections your first fall
and i remember it was just hard
adjusting to
school adjusting to a new social
environment and
wes and another one of our classmates
xavier were in
my section and i remember just like
looking over to them making eye contact
when things are a little stressful
and them looking back at me and it made
me feel
heard and supported and i knew i wasn't
alone and it can be i think it can be
really hard at transitioning into school
again and knowing that i had the vbsa
community
even though we hadn't known each other
very long that this was a safe
home space was just priceless for me
so there's a question here from brandon
about how
has the vbsa changed from when you first
joined
to today knowing that um
you know the spirit at stanford is
student-led staff supported
how has the group evolved over over your
time here
it's bigger now isn't it it's like
kind of surprising
that was all this group so i guess it is
it's bigger now which is great it's
growing
yeah um i mean what i'd add is and i i
don't think this is unique to stanford i
think
um in all the communities or
institutions that we're all at but just
the black community
has a bit of a spotlight on it or has
the this past year so
um i think there's been you know
greater appetite to both support and
learn from this community
um so i think as you can imagine that's
you know there's a lot of time and
energy that goes into that
um and then we already i think what we
spoke to earlier i think we've
we shifted we were a bit more proactive
this year and continue to be in terms of
working with can with leadership leaders
of the institution
with alums with others to um
make changes that will make this a
better place for for you all um and
we're really encouraged about um
the momentum that's been built and um
look forward to you all uh being a part
of that and carrying that forward
so there's a question here and i think
it's it's kind of related to this topic
as well
um and the question is about like mental
health and
holistic support kind of broadly knowing
that
given the challenges of business school
amid
broader social kind of dynamics
um how have how have you been able to
find those moments of mental health does
bbsa engage
and support and within that realm
what are some resources that you might
have tapped into to make sure
you're able to keep putting that one
foot in front of the other
i can say i had it kind of as a more
non-traditional student and someone who
was transitioning from just like what
was a much more progressive
probably anti-capitalist workplace
environment
and lifestyle into a traditional
business school based like a lot of
just like adjustment period and i
definitely utilized
um the like psychological support
services
there is it's called caps and i can't
break down the acronym
uh counseling and psychological services
perfect
you had it right yes um and
specifically like work to connect with
um
a practitioner who works with like black
and brown
and indigenous folks as their like
practice
area and have recommended them to
several friends
similarly so that's definitely a
resource that i'm
have been able to see them as part of my
student health fee at stanford
plus one micah helped me get set up with
caps which was really helpful
um i think the bbsa also does some more
informal stuff to help create spaces for
reflection and and deeper conversation
we have
um wind downs wednesday wind downs um
i don't really drink much so you don't
have to drink but it's just like a place
to come together and talk about
post all the um terrible stuff from
the spring and the carried into the
summer uh
we had one last week to just digest from
stress during the election
so i think we try to create those spaces
so that
um that are open low very chill
um to come and just talk with people in
the community and
and feel like you have a space to be
heard or or just listen
and i would say a lot of it is probably
more informal
and like exactly as ori said and based
in relationship of just like
if someone says something and i'm like
they lack a critical lens on race power
and gender and they need to educate
themselves
i definitely have like a great listening
ear within this group and
within these relationships um how would
you say
like is are conversations like that
common also like
outside of the bvsa environment kind of
more broadly in terms of like health and
wellness
mental health in particular
yeah i would say it's definitely i think
like all students who are on kind of a
track
and have either been working heavily
in like the many hour jobs prior to gsb
or after gsb it's definitely
kind of under discussion and we have
classmates who are particularly
interested in
or kind of consistently talking about it
as just an area of
expertise and focus um
so i do think and especially during
coveted has been on folks minds of just
how
do we stay safe and stay sane yeah so
true
um so this might be circling back to way
in the beginning of this conversation
um but wes you mentioned earlier when
we're giving the um
overview of some of the activities bbsa
does
um about like the connection to the
greater community and so this question
comes from
chisholm can you share some ways that
bbsa engages with the greater bay area
um kind of any ways that that takes
shape
yeah um so one thing i'll i'll
jump back to and as you mentioned this
is i think
our conference is a big way we do that
in terms of inviting others
in from a content perspective but i
think kind of
the essence of your question is is more
focused around
community service and engagement to be
frank i think
last year that was something a lot of us
felt was missing from
from the bvsa experience and um is
something that's a priority for us this
this year um so one of the things we're
kind of in
um in the early stages of planning is is
kind of a
leveraging black history month as a
as a powerful window to
[Music]
join forces with our alums to support
support the bay area and in particular
um communities of color and
i think we you know we're early in
figuring out what that looks like and
but but have recognized that that's a
responsibility that we carry
um as you know
black students with this privilege of
being here um
it's an opportunity to share this
experience with with others who may not
be as
as fortunate so um it's a priority for
us and
um look forward to that coming together
probably early next year
any other experiences with the group
here and and
how like whether you have or how you
hope to
kind of engage the community
i don't do this necessarily through bbsa
but more through kind of like
community efforts of like mutual aid and
other community advocacy and organizing
but mostly dc based
um and i'm still involved in that and i
think
a lot of our members do that in
different ways it's just maybe not
through the bbsa centrally of just like
orion wes had mentioned tutoring
undergrads
kind of black undergrad students um
as in a mentorship relationship and i
think there's just other ways that
people
engage mostly on an individual level
yeah
thank you okay and then we're gonna zoom
back
again i'm doing all kinds of hopping
around here
um but coming back to maybe the audience
and some of the things that are on their
minds
so we're gonna end so preview to the
last question words of wisdom for
um attendees but as you were approaching
um the application process are there
things that you really either
appreciated
or wish you had done slightly
differently um
as you were thinking about business
school and gsb in particular
i think one of the things that i
appreciated
during the application process was uh
really i think i had connected with a
couple of
people they sort of like late in the
process like uh
i would say like i think applications
were submitted in december or something
like that so for round two and i had
connected with someone like really late
maybe a couple weeks for the app and
i found uh like i was
from that point on and then through the
application process through the
admission process
and then prior to accepting my
admittance here
i think i was appreciative of the
honesty
and the transparency and the
thoughtfulness
of the people that i spoke to and i
think that that
i found to be not just a case of like
the admissions process but of gsb people
in general
um i i think i'm constantly surprised by
how thoughtful
and how um interesting and just how
how i i think there's just so much
fodder for conversation and for rich
conversation amongst
the gsp that i appreciated in that
process uh and now
um something i wish i would have done
differently i wish i would have given
myself more time to do more reflection
uh during the process i think i probably
could have in my
obviously my career aspirations are
basically the same but have evolved
but i feel like there was a lot of room
to do
some deeper reflection during the
application process that i wish i'd
taken more time to do
any other tips from um the group about
when you were applying like things to
think about
i don't think i have good tips because i
was a too
defer to admit so i applied like a long
time ago um
but something i wish in in retrospect i
spent a lot of time just trying to
answer the question
like why why stanford rather than kind
of what i was talking about
um of reflecting of like actually why i
want to do this for me not what i think
the right answer
will be and i think that just takes time
that takes talking to people
that takes doing the research about um
what this place has to offer and if you
feel like
it like fits with who you want to be um
and i think when i switch that mindset
it made answering the question for me
much easier because it was very
authentic
in what i thought i wanted and um
even though that's changed it came from
a place of truth and so when i got here
it those those um the foundations of
those answers still rang true
all right we're gonna round out with the
final question of the afternoon
so if you could give yourself one piece
of advice
as you were starting business school or
through the application process
um thinking about your year and a half
or so here
what would you tell yourself
i'll do a round here and then we can
close out the afternoon
um i think if i could go back uh
and maybe this is me this is the message
i'm giving
to you all um prospective applicants is
is you belong at the gsb and i was
very close to not applying um because
i went through tons of cycles of doubt
around
my my ability to get in and and ability
to thrive here and
um what a kind of my parting word to you
all would be
you've you've you've done the work you
more more than 90 percent of your app is
done and and the work you're doing now
is just
um piecing that into a story that
reflects
who you are at the core and um so i tell
you
i'd encourage you to tell yourself now
you do belong and and
and don't hesitate to apply we you know
this is this is a place that
you would thrive
i think i just have to echo west
i'm gonna come to west for advice next
time that was wonderful
i think something i'd add is that um
there's no
like one right way to do business school
or do the gsb
i spend a lot of time in the fall in the
winter last year being like i'm doing
this thing wrong i'm not
doing classes wrong i'm doing job search
wrong i'm doing friends wrong
but um there's no one way in whatever
way you do it
is the right way for you
yeah i think i would say to myself you
know
i think bless you put it well but
the fact that every opportunity that i
choose to engage in i'm fully capable of
taking advantage of
and i deserve every opportunity that
comes my way
and i think that was hard for me to
acknowledge and accept
early in the application process and
during my first year at stanford but
it's really about acknowledging that you
are capable of maximizing
and you should maximize every
opportunity and every
potential chance to level up or do
something different or challenge
yourself that comes your way
and that you can succeed by doing that
yeah
thank you all for those really important
words that i think
we all need to hear um regardless of
where we are in
our careers our education
sometimes just to know that we have done
the work and it's
it's okay to celebrate and get excited
about what comes next and
yes you can do it i think that's just
incredibly powerful so i want to make
sure
to give y'all a little bit of time today
because i know it
has been a long day of zoom of classes
of projects
and all of the other things that
business school asks of you
so thank you so much for sharing your
time with us today
both to our panelists as well as to our
attendees
i hope to see you throughout the week
and have a wonderful rest of your
evening
you